normalement à partir d'aujourd'hui 94
pays du monde doivent commencer à
appliquer un texte qu'ils ont signé hier
c'est ce qu'on appelle un traité
enseignants se traiter les pays
s'engagent à ne pas utiliser des enfants
pour en faire des soldats des enfants
soldats
mais comment c'est possible et il y en a
beaucoup aujourd'hui oui malheureusement
oui surtout en afrique regarder et plus
particulièrement en sierra leone au
liberia et en république démocratique du
congo regarde ses enfants ont appris à
se servir efficacement de leurs armes
pour faire la guerre
aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 300 mille
enfants soldats dans le monde
certains ont tout juste six ans souvent
ils ont été emmenés de force par l'armée
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont plus petits
plus souple que des adultes
ils peuvent donc se faufiler partout on
les envoie sur les premières lignes des
batailles ils sont aussi plus
disciplinés que des soldats adultes ils
protestent - donc les officiers peuvent
les faire obéir en leur faisant peur
mais certains enfants aussi décider de
même d'être soldat pour eux qu'ils ont
toujours connu la violence c'est normal
c'est moi qu'on bat car nous sommes
beaucoup moins nombreux que je me bats
pour sauver les miens l'avons compris
pour défendre au nom cet affreux faut
que j'arrête là vraiment oui depuis hier
le traité contre les enfants soldats
doit normalement être appliqué jeudi
normalement parce que parfois bp signe
des textes mais ne les respectent pas
alors on espère évidemment que là ils
respecteront tous leurs engagements
et puis il faut savoir aussi que des
organisations humanitaires comme
l'unicef qui s'occupe des enfants dans
le monde font tout pour qu'on arrête
d'envoyer des enfants au combat et pour
s'occuper des enfants qui ont été
choquées par la guerre
seif a réussi à sortir trois mille
enfants de l'armée du pays
ils ont tous déposé leurs armes et ont
reçu des affaires pour vivre un peu plus
comme des enfants de leur âge
lorsque nous avons été accueillis par
l'unicef j'ai compris qu'on allait enfin
s'occuper de nous et que nous allions
avoir le droit d'aller à l'école
l'éducation ça nous intéresse
aujourd'hui tous ces enfants suivent des
cours dans une école et il essaie
d'oublier leurs années de combat est ici
au bourg une vie des marionnettes
explique aux enfants que la guerre c'est
pas normal
vous avez appris une leçon dans le monde
pourrait s'inspirer
tout le monde doit vivre ensemble en
paix et en harmonie
maintenant mes enfants je vais vous
hebdo
et si vous